freunde bevor das video jetzt gleich
sofort los geht eine ganz kurze sache
eben uns war es heute in meinem shop ein
neuer sweater genommen schon zweiter
satz wetter einen reflektierenden smiley
print drauf das heißt wenn man ein foto
mit blitz dann von euch macht dann ja
knackt er in alle richtungen ich würde
mich sehr darüber freuen wenn ich
einfach mal in die beschreibung schaut
und einfach mal auf den ersten link
klickt freunde und zwar kommt ihr doch
zu diesem zweck und auf der seite des
wetters gibt es auch ein gewinnspiel das
man bei diesem gewinnspiel gewinnen kann
ist allerdings nicht irgendwas
materielles sondern ihr könnt mich
treffen und zwar bei einem exklusiven
meet and greet mit nur 200 200 leuten im
alexa holy fashion store in berlin ich
will daran nichts zu sagen
ihr findet alle teilnahmebedingungen in
meinem shop also klickt auf den ersten
sieg in der beschreibung schaurig den
sweater anschaulich das gewinnspiel an
vielleicht sehen wir uns dann beide
berlin und jetzt kommt das video hallo
mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ich war heute am
zeitschriftenladen im zeitschriftenladen
auf jeden fall gab es verschiedene
zeitschriften über autos wahlcomputer
wie war erkannt welche comics oder so
und unter anderem auch die bravo schauen
wenn das mein lieblings sportler auf
jeden fall habe ich mir gedacht ja
irgendwie hat jeder youtuber schon mal
auf doktor sommer näher geht außer ich
deswegen zum rand
[Applaus]
ich habe hier drin 14 negative poster
special von meinen lieblings stars von
riverdale von duffy von lauren graham
greene von der auch ein paar
aufgeschlagen jetzt einfach mal die
ersten seite auch wir sehen schon inhalt
es gibt titelstorys überschäumendes es
gibt sachen über justin bieber die
inspirationen hinter seinen songs
freunde das ja schnell gestaltet oder
suchen muss
wir haben themen und trends also style
star looks unter 100 euro dann haben wir
hier das muskel und wir haben auch
doktor sommer sprechstunde deine fragen
der woche dr
dieser kleine junge hier meine damen und
herren wird ist verliebt und er das ist
der norit und der zwölf jahre alt und er
schreibt ich bin in ein mädchen verliebt
und trau mich nicht persönlich zu sagen
deshalb will ich einen brief schreiben
ein brief ist es die brache von 1963
im internet finde ich aber keine vorlage
uns selbst fällt mir nichts ein habt ihr
tipps und jetzt kommt das dr sommer team
an die reihe der text muss von dir sein
eine vorlage aus dem internet oder aus
der bravo und dann kommt es das geht gar
nicht
warum gibt die braune jetzt eine vorlage
du könntest damit anfangen was du
gefühlt hast als du sie zum ersten mal
gesehen hast oder warum du dich in sie
verliebt hast du kannst auch schreiben
dass du nicht weißt was du schreiben
sollte das sonst nie tut es die aber auf
jeden fall schreiben will das trat nicht
so dick auf tragt ihr bei ihnen keinen
blick auf die ohren
nein quatsch also jetzt steht trage
nicht zu dick auf sonst wird hitzig aber
wichtig ist eigentlich nicht fassen
schreibt sondern dass du schreibst wenn
die ersten worte zu papier gebracht hat
hätte ganz sicher noch mehr ein freund
ich würde sagen wir helfen dem lorenz
und schreiben erst mal einen brief für
ihn
zunächst einmal brauchen der
kugelschreiber heißt ralf kühr zunächst
einmal meine damen und herren brauchen
wir überhaupt einen namen wie heißt die
freundin oder das mädchen in das lorenz
verliebt ist andrea andrea ja das ist
das für ein name der stift ist ein
pallotta andreas kriegenburg ein brief
liebe andrea lorenz ist gut so ja
schicken als ab nein freunde irgendwas
musste auf jeden fall noch drauf
geschrieben werden alle sind bisher so
weit lieber andrea deinen logan
dazwischen meinte dass dr sommer team
das hat mich nochmal gestiegen trat
nicht so dick auf sonst wird's kitschig
da denkst die versteht jetzt unsere
gefühle also diesen brief meine damen
und herren ich würde ich sagen am ende
des videos bringen wir die mal zur post
ich mache jetzt mal so ein bisschen so
also die andrea die vitrine zu sehen und
sie dann lieber andrea dick sein lohnt
passt doch mehr ja okay gut weiter im
programm das hier ist die 13 jährige
sophia meine damen und herren und die
sophia sagt ich vermisse meine freundin
und zwar seit meine freundin weggezogen
ist habe ich das gefühl sie will nichts
mehr von gewissen sie schreibt nicht nur
noch selten
sie schreibt mich nur noch selten über
facebook ja gut da man fehler immer wenn
ich an sie denke fangen nicht an zu
weinen
das dr sommer team schreibt schreibt ihr
wie es dir geht ja was soll sophia das
schreiben ich meine wenn ich an dich
denke die beste freundin zu vermissen
ist fast so schlimm wie liebeskummer und
wenn sie sich dann nur wenig meldet ist
das noch trauriger schreib mir doch mal
ein paar liebe zahlen wie sehr wir sie
vermisst vielleicht gibt's ja einfach
sehr wohl sie vermisst vielleicht komme
dass wir die gleiche zeile ist ein
dummkopf
vielleicht liegt es ja einfach am umzug
stress weil sie ziemlich viel um die
ohren hat oder die werte und an mädels
wochenende um recht bald mal wieder zu
sehen
sophia auch für dich schreiben wir einen
brief an eine freundin
wie heißt die freunde von sofia
auch andrea der star andrea das schiff
kommen andrea wessel top thema nummer
eins wie bei dr sommer andrea unten
schreiben wir wieder hin
weißt du was gemeint ist also damit
seine zähne stehen lieber andrea dick
dein lorenz und jetzt von der sofia die
beste bekennt sich sophia und lorenz
wohl vielleicht vielleicht sind die in
einer klasse gewesen die sophia ist dann
weckt die an die andreas dann weggezogen
und deswegen vermisst der slogan setzt
sie und so viel wir könnten lorenzo
sofia verkuppeln das doch ein brief von
lorenz 1 sophia schreiben erstmal will
ich allerdings sagen dass du diesen
brief hier noch ein bisschen finden und
zwar lieber andrea ich wäre mit
dick wir bringen die mädels und jungs
vielleicht ist der lotse auch mädchen
laut lorenz japaner also das ist jetzt
der brief von der sofia an die andrea
und jetzt machen wir noch ein brief von
dem von dem lorenz an die sofia
das meine ich natürlich meine damen und
herren von der sofia an den bmhs und
zwar schreibt diese vier jetzt über
lorenz to lorenz ich vermisse meine
freundin andrea ganz toll und ich weiß
auch dass du in sie verliebt bist wollen
wir dann vielleicht einfach zusammen
sein
daniel sofia den schweizer sitz war eben
im postkasten freunde hier ist der
postkasten meine damen und herren das
heißt wir stecken jetzt hier einfach mal
die klappe auf und stecken jetzt immer
die briefe reihen also jetzt warten wir
mal so 2000 jahre bis der post wurde
kommt 2000 jahre später im briefkasten
haben die geschrieben
[Musik]
der wahlbrief und von lorenz an sofia
last zusammen sein scheiß auf andrea
alter freude
das war wieder ein system ist der
gleiche ist wirklich verloren freunde um
das ganze team zusammen zu passen der
lorenz hat man nach dr sommer team
geschrieben es in ein mädchen verliebt
und zwar in der andrea er weiß aber
nicht wer sie schreiben sollen hat die
sophia gesagt sie vermisst ihre freundin
ganz tollen das war ebenfalls die andere
jetzt hat allerdings der lorenz der
andrea geschrieben hey andrea ich lieb
dich so sehr ich weiß nicht wie ich hier
das sagen soll dick da waren sehr schöne
brief den der uns auf jeden fall
geschrieben hat wurde hat die andrea
darauf nicht geantwortet und dann hat
die sophia der andrea noch mal
geschrieben
andrea ich vermisse dich ganz ganz
sicher darauf nicht geantwortet dann hat
sich die sophia gedacht hey wenn die
andreae weg ist dann bin ich doch
einfach mit lorenz zusammen und es hat
der lohnskala wurde in sofia kommen wir
sind ja zusammen das ist ja etwas wie
findest du das krank
[Musik]
den rahmen dafür dem lorenz und der
sozia jetzt auf jeden fall geholfen
haben der andrea des teams zu helfen
wenn du nicht mal antwortet würde ich
sagen
schauen wir uns jetzt auch hier eine
sache an die 13 jährige isabell sagt
meine eltern gehen mir echt auf die
nerven ich darf nichts nicht mal auf
einer geburtstagsparty meiner besten
freundin ich kann dieses dafür bist du
noch zu jung echt nicht mehr hören eines
steht fest ich will da hinten nur punkt
wie tja isabel du bist 13 schalten nicht
auf schuhe zunächst mal sind deine
eltern wahrscheinlich einfach nur
besorgt schon klar das ändert nichts an
der tatsache hat man vielleicht bist du
besser wenn du mit ihnen klammer klar
kommst vielleicht ist besser wenn doch
einfach mal klamotten an dass dieser
welt praxi was genau sie befürchten wenn
du aus geesthacht geht es ja um alkohol
jungs oder wandern nach hause kommst das
lässt sich alles regeln wenn du
versprichst dich an alle absprachen zu
halten und es auch tust darfst du sicher
zur party freunde da mal eine ganz kurze
reallife neu formieren wenn ich
irgendwas wollte und man erhält dann das
nur unter bestimmten bedingungen erlaubt
haben also irgendwie wenn ich dann zu
hause sein soll oder wenn ich dann keine
ahnung was machen die sonne oder so dann
habe ich das immer alles eingehalten
weil dadurch baut ihr euch im vertrauen
auf und die eltern wissen dann
irgendwann okay er ist zwar noch 15 und
vielleicht ist er zu jung für ein spiel
ab 16 aber in der vergangenheit gezeigt
dass erste absprachen hält und blablabla
ich bin immer noch voll flash verloren
und sofia
um uns jetzt mal die letzte person
hierzu können wir nicht mal wir haben
den lorenz geholfen der sophia der
andrea wie gesagt ist mehr zu helfen
isabel habe ich dir meine real story
erzählt bau dir einfach im vertrauen
darauf zu deinen eltern und wenn sie
dann sehen ob er auf dieses verlassen
dann klappt das auch als letzte person
der wir heute helfe ist die schalotte
die s14 und zwar schreibt sie in meiner
klasse ist ein total nerviger junge
erklatscht mich ständig an macht blöde
witze leute hinterher und begrapscht
nicht sogar der spinnen wohl was soll
ich tun
judo ist kann es mir schon erzählen wenn
du jedes bestehen der schule dass der
junge sich gegen seinen willen an fasst
das geht gar nicht sagt ihm dass mit
deutlichen worten und am besten wenn die
schüler dabei sind je mehr es
mitbekommen umso größer ist der druck
dass er sich auch daran hält und wenn
das nicht hilft holte verstärkung da
kann ich nur ist es egal empfehlen wenn
du alles vorhat dann rede auf jeden fall
mit seinen eltern dass er jetzt auch
gesagt oder wie heißt der junge wohl
günther könnte
durch den bernern deinen kopf zu messen
sondern an der stelle wird das heutige
video ist allerdings auch bei hätten
meine damen und herren ich habe einfach
gedacht ich habe das in dem
zeitschriften nach dem gewinn und dachte
da sind so viele hilflose zwölfjährige
denen muss das kabel muss sich einfachen
dann briefe schreiben und helfen soll
ich noch auf andere zeitschriften
reagieren doch was euch vielleicht
allgemein als nächstes reagieren
schreibt uns in die kommentare freunde
das ein leichter wie gesagt wenn es euch
gefallen hat und jetzt schauen wir mal
dass die andrea vielleicht vielleicht
ist ja auch tod stimme vor
deswegen antwortet die auch nicht